IRFAN BAQUI: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to "Apigee Up Close."
My name is Irfan Baqui.
I'm a customer engineer
with Google Cloud,
helping our customers make
better architectural decisions,
as well as better API
management decisions.
And today we'll be talking about
insights driven APIs programs.
And the objective is just
to share our philosophy
on analytics and monitoring
and relate it to your business.
I'll give you a lot of examples
of how our customers are
leveraging insights to make
their businesses better,
to make their API
programs better.
And then toward the
end, I'll take you
through a demo that will
showcase everything that we
talk about in the presentation.
But the central idea really is
that a business needs real time
insights on multiple
different levels to be agile.
And I'll show you today on how
you can get those insights.
So let's dive right into it.
I'm sure you're
familiar with Apigee.
It sits in the middle
of all of your services
and your applications.
And all of the data
that goes through
between your applications
and your services,
it goes through Apigee.
And the good thing about
this is that Apigee
has a lot of data
passing through,
and it can give you
the right insights
on how your services are
doing, both on a business level
as well as on an
operational level.
And when we are talking
about this data,
the one thing to keep in mind
is that the data is usually
associated with a
particular entity.
So on the left you
have the customer.
On the right you have
your back end systems.
And that's how the data
flows, left to right and right
to left.
And it is associated with
a customer, an application,
and a developer.
And it accesses
particular APIs, which
are part of different
products of yours.
And in turn, those APIs--
in Apigee, then, they interact
with specific back end systems.
So all of these
insights are very
specific to the
particular entity.
Thus they can give
you a good glean
on how your business and
your API program is doing.
So now let me tell you about
our philosophy behind insights.
We look at insights in a
lot of different levels,
and the first level is
just your core business.
Everything starts at
your core business KPIs.
What is your business strategy,
and what are the metrics
that you need to
track to achieve it?
And you would want
to track that.
And you can do it in
Apigee in very close
to a real-time basis.
Be it your revenue,
or your subscriptions,
or the health of your
marketing campaigns,
you can track all of
those insights in Apigee.
The second one is the insights
about your API program.
How is your API program doing?
How many developers are signing
up in a particular week?
The different applications
the developers are making,
how are they
consuming your APIs?
What are the experiences that
the end users are getting?
So all of those insights you can
get from a good API management
platform like Apigee.
The next one is at
a product level.
So within your API
program, you would
be exposing a lot of different
APIs bundled together
as a product that represent
a cohesive functionality,
and you want to see how
those products are being
consumed by your customers.
And you want to see how one
product relates to the other
and figure out how you
can make them better,
invest the right resources
to make them better.
And lastly, the
operational level
analytics for the
operations teams.
And these have to be real-time.
So if there is something
wrong in your APIs,
on Apigee or even in
your back end systems,
you want to get
alerted in real time
with the right amount of
information that will help you
solve that particular error.
And you'd be able to
get that with Apigee.
So now let me talk about
some of our customers that
are using Apigee Analytics on
all of these different levels.
So one of the customers I want
to talk about is T-Mobile.
T-Mobile is one of the largest
telecommunications providers
in the United States, and they
are reinventing themselves
as a technology company.
They are modernizing
their entire stack,
and they're using
Apigee as the API layer
on top of everything to manage
the APIs, and govern them,
and all of that.
So one of their key business
metrics that they track
are subscriptions.
And they're able to
get business insights
into how the API program is
supporting that key business
strategy and how many
subscriptions they're driving.
So the thing about T-Mobile,
it has a good online presence.
It also has a very
good brick-and-mortar,
concrete, offline presence.
It has thousands of
stores across the US,
but at the same time,
they're also selling
through big-box retailers.
And they would want to find
out what kinds of demographics
resonate better in one
channel versus the other.
The people who would buy
T-Mobile subscriptions
in the retailer Target may
be of a different demographic
than folks that buy
the subscriptions
at Best Buy or Walmart.
And you want to make sure that
you are appealing to them,
you're providing the right kind
of product to each one of them.
And that's possible by
gaining the right insights
from that demographic.
The other customer I want to
talk about is Domino's Pizza.
Now, you would think that
Domino's is in the pizza
delivery business,
but actually they
are in a B2B business servicing
their franchise owners.
And these franchisees, they have
their own IT systems, usually,
and then Domino's needs
a way to integrate
into their delivery systems
and their payment systems
and all of that.
And they are able to
do that with Apigee.
But at the same time, to
stay competitive and lure
the franchise owners in staying
with Domino's and opening up
even more franchises,
they need to provide them
with relevant
insights on how they
can make their programs better.
And with a platform like
Apigee, as all of the data
is flowing through, they would
be able to give them insights
on, what does the best
delivery experience look like?
Who are the target
demographics, what
are they interested in
across different geographies?
And what are the success
factors and success criterias
that the franchise owners
can implement to make
their businesses better?
The other customer I want to
talk to you about is Walgreens.
And Walgreens is really
a classic example
of a customer that has developed
a robust developer ecosystem.
Walgreens, if you're aware, it
is one of the largest pharmacy
chains in the United States.
And back in 2008, they
started to experience a drop
in their photo business because
folks weren't using film
roll anymore, and they were
using their smartphones instead
to take pictures.
And then it was really
important for them
to understand the
end user behaviors
and figure out how to
get those users back.
Well, they found out that
they were taking pictures
with their smartphones,
but they still
wanted to get those
pictures printed.
So they created some native
applications, mobile as well as
desktop, to
basically enable them
to get those photos printed
at a nearby Walgreens.
And that restored some
of their business,
but they said,
hey, I think there
is some more potential here.
And they started to get insights
into what kinds of pictures
were these customers printing.
And they found out that
a lot of this traffic
was coming from other photo
services that would enhance
their customers' photos.
For example, at
Halloween time you
would upload a picture
to one of these services
and decorate it with
pumpkins or something.
So they were experiencing a lot
of traffic from such services.
They said, all right, how
about I expose my photo prints
API to these different
applications and services
and incentivize them
to route their traffic
to get the photos printed
at a nearby Walgreens store?
So they did that, and
their ecosystem exploded.
There were actually new
apps that the developers
were making just to
tap into the incentives
that Walgreens would give
them to direct traffic
to their stores.
So that was very
successful, and then
they replicated that model
to other products, as well.
So now they have a plethora
of products ranging
from prescription refills,
and rewards programs, and home
delivery services that
are basically just
APIs that they're exposing.
And they're being integrated
in the developer's applications
and thereby giving more business
and traffic to Walgreens.
And they were able to do so by
really understanding their end
customers and their
shopping patterns,
as well as understanding
developers, what they need,
and incentivizing them
to partner with them
and send them the right traffic.
The next thing I
want to talk about
is operational insights
and monitoring.
And this is actually used
by a lot of our customers
in a lot of different
verticals, so I
won't give you a particular
customer's example.
But let me tell you about
the motivation, actually,
of why we created the
Monitoring module in Apigee.
So some of the largest retailers
in the US and across the globe,
actually, are
Apigee's customers.
And at critical
times of the year,
like the New Year's sale or the
Black Friday or Cyber Monday
sale, they experience
enormous amount of traffic.
So for example, in
2018, Black Friday,
we experienced close
to 110,000 transactions
per second sustained over
long durations of time.
And it's important that these
services for these customers,
they're up and running
without any disruption,
because every
second of disruption
could cost them
hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of
dollars in revenue.
So Apigee has a really
robust API availability rate.
We surpass our SLAs.
But our customers
said that, hey,
sometimes there are
things on our end
that we need to troubleshoot.
Some of our services
get down for a variety
of different
reasons, and we would
love to get some
alerts for us to be
able to fix those
issues fast and get up
and running really fast.
So that was the motivation
behind Apigee Monitoring.
It addresses a particular
need for the operations teams.
There's a lot of
pressure these days
for them to resolve issues very
fast, quickly diagnose issues,
and the data that
Apigee has, which
is specific to the
entities accessing the APIs
as well as services
that the API is tied to.
And the different
policies in your proxies
and where exactly that
error might be occurring
is very useful in diagnosing
these APIs issues.
So this is a diagram of how
Apigee Monitoring differs
from just generic
synthetic monitoring.
The thing I want
you to focus on is
that the alerts that you get--
they are precise.
They tell you exactly where
the error has occurred.
They're contextual.
If the error is due
to a race condition,
if it's intermittent,
it'll help you
zero in on what exactly is
wrong and what is triggering
that particular error.
So just to sum it up,
Apigee Analytics actually
covers all of the personas
that need insights into the API
program to make it better.
It is your business
owner to get insights
on the strategy
for the API program
and how it's doing with
relation to the different KPIs
that the business team has set.
It's to the API team can monitor
the health of the API program
and figure out what is
gaining traction, what
needs more resources; to the
app developer to gain insights
into particular API
proxies and applications;
and to ops teams to get
real-time monitoring alerts
and help in
diagnosing the issues.
So at this, let me
jump right into a demo.
So this is how the
Apigee platform looks.
You have a place to
design your APIs.
create, build your APIs,
productize them, publish
them, and all of that.
And then you have a
place for analytics.
And to the left of the
screen, as you can see,
these are the out-of-the-box
dashboards that you have
to target specific personas
within your organization.
I would like to
begin with developers
because once you
have an API program,
usually the first
thing you think
about is, how are my
developers consuming
my APIs, what is my engagement
rate, and all of that.
So this dashboard will
give us just that.
So right now as
you can see, there
is a funnel on the screen.
And you'll be able to see how
many developers have signed up
for your API program.
And out of the developers
that have signed up,
how many have actually
created applications?
How many of those
applications are active,
and how many of those
applications are highly active?
And down below
you'll be able to see
how is each of the
application performing?
What is a traffic that they
are running to the platform?
What is the error
rate, and all of that.
And then you can dig
in further to analyze
the high-level metrics.
The next thing that you
would be interested in just
for the high level is
the traffic composition.
Just tell me what are
the top 10 proxies that
are receiving the most traffic.
Tell me what are the
top applications that
are consuming my services.
What are the top 10 products
that are being accessed, being
consumed, and who are
the developers that are
the most active on my platform?
So that is more a
high-level overview
of the health of
your API program.
If you're looking
at the end users,
if you're a product
manager, you would
want to gauge, where are
my end users located?
You'll be able to do that
with the GeoMap attribute
with Apigee.
Over here, as you
can see, I have
a lot of users coming
from the United States,
but I also have global
presence in Australia, Norway,
and China, Pakistan,
a lot of places.
So if I click on the
US, I'll be able to see
the different states where
traffic is coming from.
Most of it looks like it's
coming from California.
I can dig in deeper and see
what are different counties that
are sending me this traffic.
You can also see what
are the devices that are
accessing your applications.
So over here you can see that
the most popular platform looks
like it's Chrome, and Internet
Explorer, and so on and so
forth.
Most of the traffic
is coming from the PC,
and a lot of my users are
also using the smartphone,
mostly from Windows, and also
from iOS and all of that.
So the next thing
I want to show you
is the API metrics
on a product level,
as well as on an
API proxy level.
So if I click on API Proxy
Performance, on this dashboard,
you'll be able to see what is
the health of all of my API
proxies.
For the traffic that
you have gotten,
what are the successes
and what are the errors?
You can see that my error
rate is pretty high, actually.
It's 8%.
So I need to make a
mental note that I
need to dig into what is
causing that error rate.
So we'll do that
in just a second.
You can also see that my average
response time for the proxy
is just a bit over
100 milliseconds.
For the target, it's a
bit over 250 milliseconds.
These are the traffic
patterns by proxy,
and there's the average response
time for each of the proxies.
In the same time, this
is for your proxies
that you are exposing on Apigee.
You can also get the
same kind of information
for your target back
ends that the proxies are
in turn hitting to get
the right data to execute
the right logic.
And you can see that
the traffic by target
tells you what the
traffic patterns are.
It also tells you that most
or all of it is successful.
Your back end is not showing
any errors, which is good.
Your response time,
average proxy is about 130.
Average target is close to 300.
And it also tells you a
bit about the payload.
You can also do latency
analysis, and cash performance,
and all of that.
Let me take a look at
error code analysis.
Let's see what kinds of
errors are we throwing.
So all of the errors
are proxy errors.
We knew that.
And a majority of those
errors are 400 errors,
4xx, mostly authentication
and bad request
and all of that, which is good.
We want to deny those requests.
But a small percentage of
it is also 500, 5xx errors.
We should look into that, what
exactly is going on there.
It also tells me what
is the error by proxy.
It looks like my
product search proxy
is receiving or generating
the most amount of errors.
So we'll take a look at that.
Errors by target, and also
proxy errors by response code.
And most of the response code
is 401 or 500 and some 502s.
So we'll look into that as well.
Now let's dive right into some
of the business-level metrics.
So I mentioned that we
have a lot of customers
that are using these tools
to gain business level
insights on their revenues,
and on the marketing campaigns,
and all of that.
So let me show you
how you can do it.
So these are-- what I showed
you are out-of-the-box reports.
You have a lot of
metrics and data
available so that you can
create your own custom reports.
So let's say you are
a big-box retailer,
and you have a lot of retail
locations all across the globe.
For that, let's say I
want a revenue report
on how each one of my
locations are doing.
So I'll run this report
for the past hour,
as I just want it
to be real-time just
to monitor the health.
And it will tell me that
the majority, or the highest
revenue grossing store
was my US 15 store.
And my stores in
India, Norway, Pakistan
are doing pretty well as well,
as they are in the top 10.
Let's say, on the
other hand, you
are running a
marketing organization,
and you want to see the health
of your marketing campaigns.
Then let's take a look
at the marketing report.
Let's run it for the past hour.
So over here you can see
that your traffic is divided
into three different blocks, and
one chunk is from social media.
So let's take a look in there.
As you can see, the
report is interactive.
It tells me that I have a few
different campaigns running.
One is a data privacy campaign.
There's also the money
back guarantee campaign
and all of that.
And it tells me what is
the traffic composition
from each one of these.
It looks like my expert
conversation campaign is
grossing the least
amount of traffic,
so I hope that I'm also spending
the least amount of money
on that and the revenue per
dollar spent on that campaign
is worth my time.
So let's click on the
data privacy campaign
and look at what
kinds of channels
that the traffic is coming from.
It looks like most of
it is coming from blogs.
There's also some from Google,
LinkedIn, some influencer
marketing going on, and
the least amount of traffic
from Twitter and Instagram.
So it gives me a good
insight into what
is working for my campaigns
versus what is not working.
So now lastly what I want to
show you is API monitoring.
And API monitoring is about
how is the health of your API
program in real time?
So what you're seeing right
now is basically a dashboard.
It tells you what is the TPS
that your org is experiencing,
what is the error rate, what is
the latency, and all of that.
So one feature I want
to call out over here
is the alerting feature.
So over here, I've set a
500 error alert to alert me
whenever my proxy surpasses a
threshold for the 500 errors.
And that threshold I've
set is that if there
is a constant rate of 3%
or higher for five minutes,
then please alert
me, and send me
an alert to this
particular email.
You can choose
whatever mode you want.
You can integrate
it with anything
you want, with webhook, or
PagerDuty, or Slack, or email.
So if I go to my
inbox, I was actually
getting some 500 alerts.
And I got a few
alerts just recently.
So let me take a look at this,
that I got about a day ago.
And it tells me that there's
a playbook for me to use
to troubleshoot that alert.
It also gives me the details
on exactly what the alert is.
So let me click on View Details.
So it'll take me to a report
in the Investigation panel
on API Monitoring.
It tells me that, hey,
the status code is 500,
and here was a spike
that I'm looking at.
It was constant, or
it was pretty stable
at that threshold for
about five minutes.
And that's how it got
triggered, is right here.
It tells me that the
rate limit policy
that I have is triggering this.
So now I have a
pretty decent idea
of what exactly is going on.
I click on this.
It tells me that the
environment is production.
This is the proxy.
So if you recall from earlier,
the Product-Search proxy
was also a proxy that was
throwing the most errors,
so I'm not surprised by this.
And it looks like a
lot of applications
are affected by this
particular error.
So that's good to
know, and it also
gives me some other detail in
terms of the message processor,
and also the target that
my API proxy is calling
as part of these API calls.
And down below it tells
me that most of the errors
are generated from
the proxy itself,
and there are very
few from the target.
So 3,500 from the proxy itself.
So now I know
exactly where to go.
I know the particular
proxy that is impacted,
and I know the policy
within the proxy
that is throwing these errors.
So let me now go to Develop.
Let me click on API Proxies.
And now I'll go into the
Product-Search proxy,
and I'll go into Develop.
And this is the
SpikeArrest policy
that is throwing those errors.
It looks like I'm
saying that, hey,
if I receive more than
three requests per second,
then please throw errors.
Don't let them pass
through, because I think
that is higher than I expect.
I think three
requests per second--
let's say I do some
analysis, I look
at the capacity of
back end systems,
and I feel like I could
probably increase it
to seven requests per
second and save it.
And now it's deployed,
and basically that's it.
Now I should expect
those error rates
to go down because my
SpikeArrest policy will
get triggered less often.
So this is basically what the
Apigee Analytics and monitoring
looks like.
So that's it for today.
Thank you for joining.
You can find more webinars
coming out every week,
so please tune in for that.
And you can also find
recordings of our past webinars
on our YouTube channel.
Thanks again for joining.
Take care.
Bye.